s'il y a des collègues qui nous rejoint
non mais on va y aller parce qu'après
même même autour de la table je sais que
j'ai une collègue qui va peut-être nous
quitter pour rejoindre la séance voilà
bien mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons donc les travaux de
notre mission d'information sur le
développement d'une filaire filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert par l'audition
de Monsieur Boris Ravignon président par
intérim du conseil d'administration de
l'Agence de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie monsieur Ravignon
est accompagné de Monsieur David Marchal
directeur exécutif adjoint de
l'expertise et des programmes
alors cette réunion c'est pour ça que je
suis introduit comme ça cette réunion
est captée et diffusée en direct sur le
site internet du Sénat sur lequel elle
pourra ensuite être consulté en vidéo à
la demande monsieur Ravignon je rappelle
que vous avez été nommé président du
conseil d'administration de l'ADEME le
22 décembre dernier à la suite du départ
de votre prédécesseur Monsieur Arnaud
Leroy
cette première nomination faite à
l'issue d'audition par les commissions
compétentes de l'Assemblée nationale et
du Sénat conformément à la procédure
prévue par l'article 13 de la
Constitution valait pour la durée du
mandat de votre prédécesseur restant à
courir le conseil d'administration de la
dame vient d'être intégralement
renouvelé par le décret du 3 mars
dernier et vous êtes à nouveau proposé
par le Président de la République pour
exercer les fonctions de président du
conseil d'administration de l'Agence
vous serez donc entendu de nouveau
prochainement par les commissions
parlementaires compétentes en l'espèce
au Sénat par la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable c'est pour cette
raison que nous vous entendons
aujourd'hui en tant que président par
intérim
je rappelle également que vous êtes
maire de Charleville-Mézières et
président Dardenne
métropole depuis
2014 et si j'ai bien lu amoureux des
Ardennes c'est d'ailleurs en tant que
mère de Charleville-Mézières que vous
siégé désormais au conseil
d'administration de la dame alors que
vous l'étiez les mois précédents qualité
de représentants de l'État vous avez
aussi été vice-président de la région
Grand Est en charge de l'économie des
fonds européens et de la commande
publique de juillet 2021 à décembre 2022
et conseiller général des Ardennes de
2008 à 2015 monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Directeur exécutif adjoint
notre mission d'information comprend 23
membres
tous retenus en séance presque
issue des différentes commissions et
représentant l'ensemble des groupes
politiques du Sénat
avec mes collègues nous sommes
convaincus de l'enjeu que représente le
développement des filières de
biocarburant et de carburant
synthétiques durable et hydrogène vert
tant pour la capacité de la France que
pour l'Union européenne a atteint
l'objectif de neutralité climatique à
l'horizon 2050 que pour notre
souveraineté et la compétitivité de
notre économie l'ADEME joue un rôle
essentiel dans la conduite de la
stratégie de l'État en ce domaine elle
soutient financièrement par le biais
d'appel à projet de nombreuses actions
je pense par exemple au 14 nouveaux
lauréats de l'appel à projet sur les
écosystèmes territoriaux hydrogène opéré
par l'ADEME qui ont été dévoilés
dernièrement je pense également aux
appels à projets relatifs au
biocarburant conventionnés comme
avancées je pense enfin aux appels à
projets liés au plan de relance et
d'investissement
qui peut servir de guide mais vous
vous envisagez librement comme vous
voulez votre propos
introductrice introductif je passerai
éventuellement la parole à mes collègues
mais je passerai tout de suite la parole
après votre intervention à notre
rapporteur et des questions que notre
rapporteur vous a envoyé vous pouvez
nous transmettre ultérieurement les
réponses par écrit à ces questions
monsieur Ravignon je vous cède la parole
on va dire pour une quinzaine de minutes
effectivement même si on s'entend bien
cette distance je pense que pour
l'enregistrement ce sera mieux
effectivement que le micro soit allumé
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
juste peut-être une précision pour vous
indiquer puisque je crois que la date
vient d'être fixée que l'audition parle
la commission du développement durable
l'aménagement du Sénat devrait se faire
le 12 avril prochain je crois pour la
renomination
ça
voilà ça vient de ça vient tout juste
d'être fixé à nouveau
sujet de coordination naturellement avec
la commission
équivalente du de l'Assemblée nationale
et donc effectivement
la dame vous le rappeliez fait ce
effectuer ce travail de d'éclairer
l'avenir de d'éclairer les trajectoires
de notre pays et à réaliser il y a
maintenant
la première publication c'était fin 2021
je crois un très gros travail d'analyse
de prospective qui s'appelle transition
2050 qui s'efforce effectivement
d'imaginer différents scénarios nous
permettant tous d'atteindre c'est le
point commun de des quatre scénarios qui
sont identifiés nous permettant
d'atteindre effectivement la neutralité
carbone à l'horizon 2050
alors c'est c'est travaux ont été depuis
complétés par l'édition d'un certain
nombre de de feuilletons et puis
d'autres encore qui sont qui sont à
venir c'est c'est très très largement
les services placés sous l'autorité
David Marchal qui qui travaillent sur
ces sur ces sur ces éléments là et les
publis et donc on a un feuilleton qui
avait été très attendu sur la le mix
électrique et puis là on s'apprête à
publier je crois des éléments sur les
matériaux et les matières les matières
premières puisque il y a et on va y
revenir derrière les choix qui qui sont
faits sur le plan énergétique une
question forcément de disponibilité des
ressources qui est tout à fait crucial
alors je
vais pas faire durer plus longtemps le
suspense dans cette dans tous ces
scénarios que nous envisageons et bien
le recours à des carburants moins
carbonés que ceux que nous qui existent
aujourd'hui une décarbonation des
carburants et absolument nécessaire il
constitue un point important de la
teinte des objectifs mais elle constitue
une enfin ce recours hélas pas suffisant
on a pour le décarbonation soit soit
complète on a un certain nombre de
d'autres éléments je veux simplement les
rappeler en préambule qui figure
vraiment dans les dans les messages
importants récurrents de l'ADEME c'est
vraiment tout d'abord de faire
progresser la sobriété y compris dans le
domaine des transports dans le domaine
de la mobilité alors ça ça nous renvoie
aux politiques d'autopartage de
covoiturage de pouvoir d'encouragement
au télétravail
puisque on peut démontrer pourra
démontrer dans que que le télétravail
permet effectivement
sous certaines conditions une économie
mais notamment une économie importante
en matière de transport en un report
vers des modes de transport qui sont
effectivement plus respectueux alors on
les appelle mobilité active la marche le
vélo la trottinette de tout ce qu'on
veut et puis bien sûr aussi les
transports en commun le train et et
l'amélioration d'efficacité énergétique
encore des des chaînes de traction des
véhicules c'est-à-dire qu'on a surtout
des gains à réaliser en sobriété en
efficacité et dans la sobriété je mets
le recours à d'autres modes de transport
que que le véhicule individuel ou les
véhicules que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
alors dans notre vision prospective et
on a des couples véhicules carburant des
carbonés qui diffèrent selon selon les
secteurs j'ai rapidement les les passer
en revue et on aura peut-être l'occasion
d'y revenir
sachant que d'ores et déjà que le sujet
le plus compliqué celui sur lequel la
décarbonation sera la plus difficile à
effectuer c'est celle de secteur aérien
d'en reparler puis je serai peut-être
ensuite David compléter si sur certains
points
c'était que je ne sois pas allé au fond
des subtilités techniques de de ces
sujets et il y en a quelques-unes donc
sur la mobilité routière légère on
s'oriente a priori plutôt
majoritairement vers l'électricité
batterie alors
cette phrase a été écrite oui et je la
prononce au lendemain de de déclaration
de l'Allemagne qui tente à remettre un
peu en question
le choix
de de la fin de commercialisation des
véhicules thermiques certains que qu'il
aille que cette démarche aille à son
terme et aboutissent effectivement une
remise en cause par rapport à laquelle
d'ores et déjà l'ensemble des
industriels européens et notamment
français ce sont ce sont calés
réorganiser donc sur la partie mobilité
routière légère on ne voit pas nous de
place significative pour pour les
biocarburants à l'horizon là encore 2050
d'ici là
on peut passer par d'autres étapes mais
à cet horizon là on voit plutôt
effectivement
l'électricité batterie sur la mobilité
routière lourde en revanche s'agit de
transport ou de
voyageurs ou de marchandises on pense là
effectivement que qu'on a un peu tous
les types de carburants alternatifs qui
aujourd'hui peuvent jouer leur un rôle
et biocarburant liquides ou gazeux
encore un peu de d'électricité batterie
qui semble pouvoir exister sur pour
certains types de transport et puis
l'hydrogène en tant que tel
effectivement doit pouvoir y figurer
figurer dans les dans les sources
d'énergie s'agissant du transport
fluvial on serait selon nos avis plutôt
sur une combinaison entre électricité
batterie et puis la combustible
hydrogène
dans le dans le domaine du maritime on a
on voit là plutôt les besoins assez
largement couverts par les électro fuel
enfin donc les
icarburants électrocarburant hydrogène
l'ammoniaque l'électromethane
électromécole enfin les trucs une série
mais je imagine que en terme de cette
mission vous serez des spécialistes de
tous ces de tous ces produits compte
tenus
les carburants synthétiques de demain et
une part probablement minoritaire et le
plus minoritaire mais de biocarburant
des biogenelles et baissant notamment
on doit préciser qu'on dans notre
analyse sur le transport maritime ça
s'accompagnera très certainement d'un
d'une généralisation de l'assistance
velik donc du vent qui permet alors pas
en tant que tel de ne suffit pas mais
qui qui certaines dans certains cas
permet effectivement de soulager
énormément la consommation d'énergie et
puis peut-être aussi il faut quand même
le mentionner d'une baisse moyenne de
vitesse commerciale de circulation des
bateaux mais ça c'est effectivement un
sujet qui probablement le plus difficile
à
estimer dès aujourd'hui
dans le ferroviaire on plutôt
l'impression que c'est l'électrique qui
soit par l'électrification des lignes
mais ça ça restera
probablement limité un certain nombre de
d'itinéraires mais surtout plutôt par le
train batterie c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
fait l'objet d'une communication
enfin léger innovant ces jours-ci de la
consortiumondie par la SNCF c'est plutôt
sur cette cette piste là peut-être un
plus léger avec des batteries
électriques pour circuler justement sur
les lignes qui sont aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas électrifiées et puis donc reste
le sujet de de l'aérien qui est le point
de vue de l'ADEME est effectivement le
secteur le plus complexe à des carbonées
d'ailleurs a-t-elle enseigne que dans ce
domaine on envisage en 2050 qu'il reste
du curézen kérosène fossil dans dans les
consommations pour les transports
aériens
alors
mais mais par cette cette existence et
subsistance de kérosine fossiles on
pense qu'on sera sur une part
majoritaire de carburant décarbonés donc
effectivement les biocérosène et des
électro kérosènes
qui sont effectivement donc les les
carburants de synthèse produits à partir
de d'hydrogène et de CO2 alors tous ces
enseignements ils sont issus enfin pour
nous de l'exercice transition 2050 c'est
ce que je vous dis là c'est
effectivement les éléments qu'on a on
retrouve dans le temps dans ces
différents scénarios il inclut aussi et
il paraît être renforcé par l'existence
d'ores et déjà de d'objectif
réglementaires importants notamment
d'objectifs européens d'un corporation
de biocarburant ou carburant de synthèse
et notamment pour l'aviation ou rifi all
you sur la partie aviation et bien pose
un objectif
2050 dans Corporation 85% de carburant
aéronautique durable dont 50% minimum de
Dee kérosène je crois que ça fait
l'objet de la question 7 de de du
questionnaire qui nous a été transmis
sur lequel on revient plus longuement
alors
le contexte réglementaire qui dans les
autres domaines n'est pas totalement
stabilisé mais dans la dans l'aérien
cadre qui qui semble fixer et donc
emportait d'ores et déjà un certain
nombre de de
nous permettre un certain nombre de
calcul d'ores et déjà et notamment sur
ce que la consommation de ces carburants
de synthèse génère comme besoin en
termes de ressources
donc là les ressources qui sont
utilisées pour produire ces biocarbures
la biomasse le CO2 l'eau les différences
notamment les ressources électriques et
bien vont se trouver sur cette période
si 2050 on concurrence avec un certain
nombre d'autres
usages et d'autres d'autres secteurs
donc on a être vigilant sur
disponibilité d'abord de l'hydrogène
intermédiaire effectivement pour tous
les électro fuel mais aussi un carburant
direct je viens de le rappeler a priori
pour la mobilité routière lourde et et
restera aussi un intrant pour pour
l'industrie un informatiaire dans un
certain nombre de d'activités la
biomasse qui est un sujet qui
effectivement je crois nous préoccupe
tous aujourd'hui c'est la question du
bouclage biomasse capacité effectivement
à produire la biomasse suffisante pour
tous les usages qui sont qui sont
envisagés et qu'il s'agissent
effectivement de matériaux de
construction de l'alimentation qui sont
extérieurs à nos sujets ou dans le dans
le champ énergétique et bien différentes
qualités et de biomasse nécessaire du
CO2 qui est effectivement dans un
certain nombre de cas recombinés avec de
l'hydrogène pour produire les
électrophes et dont la disponibilité sur
les sites de besoins et tous au feu
trivial et puis la consommation
électrique et on s'amusait si on peut
dire les choses ainsi à calculer
ce que ce que rifuel you aviation
générerait comme besoin électrique et on
à l'horizon 2050 pour simplement tenir
les objectifs d'incorporation derrière
donc il y a l'utilisation de
l'électricité et on s'aperçoit qu'on est
on est à entre 17 et 28% de la
consommation électrique nationale donc
tenir actuel
tenir aujourd'hui
les engagements de de les obligations
d'incorporation de reflux sur les
électrocarburants aboutit à une
consommation électrique quand même
extrêmement significative de l'ordre du
quart au moins le cas enfin autour du
quart de la consommation électrique
actuelle donc
je crois qu'il
alerte sur le fait qu'il y a il y a là
effectivement
sur les sur les ressources qui seront
nécessaires à ces bio-carburant il y
aura il va falloir déterminer finalement
des fléchages d'utilisation de ces
ressources biomasse notamment et
hydrogène pour arriver à produire les
les notamment les biocarburants les
électrocarburants qui ont vraiment le
moins de substituts possible et présente
en termes de rendement énergétique les
perspectives les plus intéressantes on
peut effectivement imaginer on peut
toujours imaginer puisqu'on n'est pas
dans un monde clos mais
aux échanges sont possibles on peut
imaginer effectivement des importations
d'importations d'hydrogène ou même de
carburant de synthèse bon
c'est envisageable techniquement mais
mais ça rejoint les questions de d'abord
de souveraineté et puis quand même aussi
capacité à tracer l'origine et la le
caractère réellement durable des des
productions qui seraient ainsi importées
donc je pense que on devrait pas
imaginer un recours trop important ou
autre ponctuel et autres outre ponctuel
aux importations en la matière
voilà quelle sorte est ramassées je
dirais de manière très très synthétique
un peu les enseignements qui que qu'on
peut dégager très gros travail de
prospective qui a été réalisé par par
l'ADEME et qui nous a aussi encore servi
à répondre donc aux différentes
questions qui nous ont été posées par
monsieur le rapporteur sur le 30
questions que nous avons reçues on s'est
appliqué à répondre et petit document là
qui à ce stade mais n'est pas encore
tout à fait complet mais fait déjà 58
pages d'éléments concrets précis que que
nous allons pouvoir vous remettre en
réponse assez différente question
merci juste une petite précision de
passer la parole à notre apporteur vous
avez dressé les différents modes de
déplacement vous avez parlé des
véhicules légers et pour les véhicules
lourds
où j'ai pas entendu
biocarbures
électriques en partie et hydrogène merci
beaucoup
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président merci d'avoir votre
présentation et en particulier d'avoir
indiqué ce que l'on peut estimer être
des couples véhicules carburant des
carbonés je pense que c'est un effort de
pédagogie et synthèse qui est louable
alors peut-être d'abord vous nous direz
est-ce que vous estimez que cette vision
là telle que vous la présentez partagez
par les pouvoirs publics et est-ce que
vous estimez qu'elle est assez traduite
dans les à la fois dans les dans les
textes dans les engagements est-ce
qu'elle est portée
et puis ensuite est-ce qu'elle est
déclinée parce que la question qu'on se
pose c'est naturellement de savoir si on
va être capable alors vous l'avez aimée
de l'aborder d'ailleurs en partie de
constituer les filières est-ce que nous
avons suffisamment de mécanismes
incitatifs aujourd'hui quel est l'état
des lieux vous même au titre de l'ADEME
vous pratiquez un certain nombre
d'appels à projet est-ce que la démarche
vous paraît efficace parce que il y a
après
plusieurs dizaines de d'entreprises
encore qui ont été annoncées je crois
comme L'Oréal d'un appel à projet il y a
quelques jours c'était sur le domaine de
l'hydrogène et il y en a sur d'autres
domaines mais est-ce que ça vous paraît
être la bonne démarche est-ce qu'on
n'est pas en train de faire un peu du
ponctuel
et est-ce que la stratégie
du pays en matière de décarbonation
s'agissant de l'hydrogène vert des
carburants synthétiques durables et des
biocarburants est-ce que ces stratégie
vous paraît assez opérationnelle vous
venez de poser vous-même d'ailleurs la
question implicitement en disant que il
y avait quand même un sujet de
souveraineté avec l'idée que on importe
vous avez cité tout à l'heure notamment
l'aérien on voit bien que Air France a
fait des annonces et sur un certain
nombre de de carburants d'issaf
on va passer des Air France on va passer
des contrats avec des sociétés
étrangères
parce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'échanger une dépendance pour une autre
là-dessus bon on a quelques questions
que je voulais déjà vous vous posez mais
surtout vos propres appels à projets et
la démarche qui est engagée jusque là
est-ce qu'il vous paraît au vu de tout
ça manquez qu'est-ce que vous nous
suggériez d'étudier comme piste pour
rendre cette transition plus plus
opérationnelle s'il y a des transitions
législatives évolutions législatives
qu'il faudrait
mettre en oeuvre pour lever un certain
nombre de frein s'agissant de ces
filières et ensuite est-ce que vous avez
identifié des volumes vous l'avez en
partie
abordé
en disant que la conséquence de toute
façon quelque soit les choix de filière
ça sera de produire plus d'électricité
à partir de là est-ce que ce constat
vous paraît par partager et
quelle est la réponse qui est envisagée
aujourd'hui 25% de production électrique
en plus est-ce que c'est un autre portée
à court terme semble-t-il non et donc
quelle est la conséquence pour rendre
notre démarche un peu plus efficace
alors je laisserai ensuite peut-être à
David le soin de rentrer un peu plus
dans le détail mais je crois
effectivement que c'est les constats
conformé la dame sont aujourd'hui
partagés et alimentent les choix
notamment qui sont faits sur la
répartition les appels à projets de
France 2030 on a quand même aujourd'hui
je pense simplement l'exemple de de
l'hydrogène
la conscience qu'on est encore une phase
assez préalable que tout n'est pas tout
n'est pas écrit et qu'on a le besoin de
vérifier comment par exemple sur
l'objet de l'appel à projet que vous
citiez sur des écosystèmes locaux on
sait faire fonctionner de la production
d'hydrogène des carbonée et avec des
utilisations testées justement les
utilisations les plus pertinentes donc
on est encore dans une phase je crois
d'apprentissage et de construction de de
modèles sur le solidrogène mais ce que
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
correspond
aux trajectoire et aux transitions
telles qu'on les envisage alors est-ce
que c'est ces stratégies sont
suffisamment opérationnelles je crois
qu'elles correspondent effectivement à
l'état de développement de aussi de
maturité de ces de ces différents
projets sur les carburants de synthèse
on est sauf
erreur de ma part encore beaucoup au
stade de pilote ou démonstrateur donc on
est encore sur des phases où on
accompagne l'effort d'innovation des
acteurs et puis on fera effectivement
ensuite comment ces différentes énergies
différents carburants de synthèse
peuvent trouver leur place sur le marché
mais je vais peut-être laisser David
compléter sur sur ce point
notamment de des appels à projets qu'on
réalise et qui qui nous permettent à la
fois d'éclairer l'avenir c'est une
partie de notre métier et puis
effectivement d'essayer d'accompagner
les acteurs aux différents phases de
Mathieu enfin aux étapes leur stade de
maturité dans lesquels ils sont pour
pour leur permettre de progresser
peut-être avec l'autorisation du
président pour l'illustrer mon propos on
entend parfois le constat suivant c'est
que l'Allemagne sur les carburants ont
dites synthèse auraient deux trois ans
d'avance sur nous en termes de capacité
productive
et ensuite on se dit aussi que l'Europe
était partie plutôt que les États-Unis
en termes d'objectif
mais finalement maintenant se rattrapé
parce que après tout les États-Unis ont
moins de complexité
et ce sont dotés de mécanismes incitatif
alors que nous on est plutôt dans un
militaire des mécanique de taxation
voilà
alors ce sont parfois des opinions qui
se discutent ou des clichés mais je la
mettrais éventuellement
pour reprendre sur ce point là
concerne les carburants on est sur un
dispositif en France qui a une
obligation d'incorporation donc qui est
sur les biocarburants à la fois
bucarburant de première génération et de
seconde génération donc c'est pas
véritablement une taxation c'est plutôt
une obligation d'un coopération avec
effectivement des surcoûts qui reposent
sur le consommateur infini aujourd'hui
les objectifs d'incorporation qui était
fixés dans dans la loi ils sont atteints
sur les biocarburants de première et
deuxième génération la question c'est
effectivement pourquoi il n'y a pas de
développement plus massif des carburants
des biocarburants de seconde génération
alors qu'on a financé effectivement des
démonstrateurs à l'échelle une un des
démonstrateurs industriels ces années
passées
là il y a une question de de taille des
investissements ça nécessite des
investissements massifs et de
d'amortissement de durée d'amortissement
donc une question de visibilité je pense
pour les pour les industriels
globalement les cadres d'intervention de
sur ces sujets là comme sur tous les
sujets de la transition ont été fixés au
travers de France 2030 via des
stratégies d'accélération
et il y a eu des stratégies d'accès
d'accélération sur les carburants
durables il y a eu des stratégie
d'accélération sur l'hydrogène sur la
décarbonation de l'industrie et dans ces
stratégies d'accélération les différents
leviers de politiques publiques ont tous
été passés en revue pour voir comment à
la fois favoriser la transition et
développer l'industrie enfin le tissu
industriel favorable à cette transition
en France et donc c'est pour ça par
exemple sur l'hydrogène on a différents
dispositifs qui sont en place à la fois
de l'aide à la R&D donc plutôt à mon à
la fois du développement de briques
technologique là aussi plutôt sur la
main pour soutenir les équipementsiers
et puis le soutien a des premiers
déploiements donc vous parlez tout à
l'heure des écosystèmes territoriaux
hydrogène où là on soutient le
déploiement de bus de mobilité hydrogène
de Ben ordures ménagères sur le sur les
territoires et puis enfin il y a une
réflexion par les pouvoirs pouvoir là
sur des aides à l'OPEX donc des aides au
fonctionnement pour des gros
électrolyseurs voilà donc ça cette
réflexion est encore en cours mais c'est
un peu toute la la panoplie des
instruments de politique publique mis en
place dans une stratégie d'accélération
donc de l'amont à Laval pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une cohérence globale
de l'action de l'État donc sur les
biocarburants et les électrocarburants
on a de la même façon une stratégie
d'accélération et les l'étape où on en
est d'y faire un peu selon la
technologie comme je disais sur les
biocarburants de seconde génération on a
financé des gros démonstrateurs
industriels qui ont démontré la
faisabilité technique donc là maintenant
il faut passer à l'étape supérieure sur
les électrocarburants notamment pour
l'aviation il y a eu un appel à projet
donc de piloté par l'ADEME dans France
2030 qui a permis de financer des
principalement à ce stade des études de
préfiguration de ce que serait des
usines de fabrication de de ces
électrocarburant s en France avec un
certain nombre de lauréat une quasiment
une dizaine de lauréats pour
l'implantation d'usine en France donc
l'étape d'après
qui devrait venir prochainement c'est un
appel à projet pour véritablement
financer ces
usines une fois que ces études de
préfiguration auront été faites donc on
a quand même toute une panoplie
d'instruments la question après ce que
vous posez c'est comment on va inciter à
l'utilisation de ces carburants
puisque
[Musique]
il est certain que c'est carburants
présentent tous des surcos notables par
rapport au kérosène actuel notamment
dans l'aviation que ce soit les
biocarburants ou les électrocarburants
on estime qu'en 2030 on aura toujours
des surcours d'à peu près x 3 pour les
biocarburants de seconde génération et x
5 à minima pour les électrocarburants
et donc ça c'est en 2030 c'est la vision
en 2030 donc se pose la question de
comment on subventionne pour faire
décoller les filières c'est une chose et
également comment on conserve un signal
prix enfin de toute façon ça sera aussi
en lien avec la tonne de CO2 avec le
marché du carbone européen conserve un
signal prix pour inciter à une certaine
forme de sobriété comme le disait
Boris d'entrée aujourd'hui dans les
scénarios que nous on a pu évaluer sur
le transport aérien
on a des scénarios qui vont d'une
stabilité du trafic entre aujourd'hui et
2050 à une multiplication par deux du
trafic entre aujourd'hui et 2050 qui
correspond à une vision plus compatible
avec celle de la de la filière et donc
ça c'est une étude qu'on a publié fin
2022 sur la décarbonation de l'aérien
qui envisage trois scénarios
isotrafiques plus 50% de trafic et
multiplication par deux du trafic
passager aérien avec des solutions de
décarbonation soit 100% basées sur les
technologies donc typiquement
électrocarburant
biocarburant soit
donc des scénarios et notamment qui font
davantage appel à la sobriété notamment
celui qui est à ISO trafic
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
même dans le scénario qui est très
orienté technologique on a une baisse de
trafic quand même voilà parce que
finalement il y a un surcoût tel que
on a une baisse de ta vie donc tout ça
pour vous dire que par rapport au point
qui ont été soulevés sur les ressources
les tensions sur les ressources et sur
les coûts
il me semble important que que votre
commission prenne aussi en compte une
certaine nécessité de certes des
carbonée via avec ses carburants mais
d'inciter à une consommation modérée
aussi de ces carburants vous avez parlé
d'importation
une question je crois sur sur Oui c'est
vous monsieur le rapporteur qui avait
cité Air France
et là ça rejoint la question de la
planification aujourd'hui ce sont des
secteurs qui avancent très vite
notamment le secteur des
électrocarburants qui était balbutiant
il y a quelques années lors de la
dernière programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie on ne parlait pas d'électro
carburant ou alors c'était de la
science-fiction aujourd'hui il est clair
que dans la future planification
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
qui a intégré à la à la sphèque
la question doit être traitée quelle
part on donne à la production locale de
ces carburants ce qui va rejoindre cette
vision planificatrice répondre à ces
questions de souveraineté
mais il n'en reste pas moins que des
acteurs économiques pourront
effectivement chercher à importer un
moindre coût ailleurs et donc là le
chantier est encore ouvert on a pu voir
par exemple pendant la crise énergétique
des acteurs notamment dans le domaine
des engrais finalement substitutés des
importations de
[Musique]
de gaz oui voilà parce que pour faire de
l'engrais il faut du gaz naturel donc
substituer des importations de gaz à des
importations directes d'ammoniac qui
était fabriqué à l'étranger avec du gaz
moins cher ailleurs donc finalement ces
acteurs économiques qui sont agiles et
ils vont switcher très facilement d'un
vecteur à l'autre et je parle de ces de
je parle sciemment de de gaz et
d'ammoniac puisque ce sont des vecteurs
en même temps
l'ammoniac sert à fabrication des
engrais mais c'est en même temps un
vecteur énergétique est envisagé comme
l'un des vecteurs par exemple pour des
carboner le maritime voilà
donc ce sont des marchés mondiaux il
faut l'avoir en tête donc la question de
la souveraineté elle est elle est à mon
sens vraiment primordial
l'envisager en tendance parce que on est
on est aujourd'hui sur des carburants
dans le domaine des mobilités quel que
soit les qui sont dans leur écrasante
majorité importée donc on va dans tous
les cas on doit pouvoir arriver quand
même largement à regagner de la
souveraineté donc ensuite la question
faut-il aller jusqu'à l'autarcie
c'est-à-dire fonctionner sans
importation sans échange c'est c'est un
sujet mais en tout état de cause on va
dans ce domaine là assurément à la fois
décarbonée et regagner en souveraineté
c'est les deux paraissent là aujourd'hui
assez bien engagé même si il restera il
restera naturellement de des limites et
certainement des quelques échanges avec
avec notamment des les zones voisines ou
on pourrait avoir enfin la question de
la production notamment de l'hydrogène
Méditerranée pays ensemble voisins à des
coûts très faibles clairement
on voit les réflexions qui existent
aujourd'hui sur le la construction
d'hydrogénoduc permettant de capter de
faire arriver en Europe cet hydrogène
probablement très bas coût et plus bas
coût que celui que on pourra produire
localement sur de petits systèmes même
s'ils ont leur cohérence alors dans une
logique de de planification énergétique
c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir une
préférence pour une souveraineté
française assurée à 100% et nous dans
les scénarios qu'on a proposé c'est bien
dans ces deux petites qu'on s'est placé
dans trois scénarios sur 4 il y a un des
scénarios où on s'est dit bah par
exemple une partie de l'hydrogène
pourrait être importée pour aussi être
représentatif
de la société 2050 qui dessine devant
nous et essayer de d'élargir le aussi le
champ des possibles dans ce travail
exploration qui est la prospective
parmi les politiques publiques nous
interrogiez sur les leviers de
politiques publiques à mettre en place
aujourd'hui les stratégies
d'accélération dont je parlais ont été
élaborés en silo
l'industrie d'un côté les carburants
aériens de l'autre l'hydrogène de
l'autre c'est clair que avec l'angle des
électrocarburants on voit que ces
stratégies finalement rentrent pas en
concurrence mais en tout cas elles sont
elles ont des points de convergence fort
notamment sur les ressources utilisées
le CO2 notamment qui est capté qui va
être capté dans l'industrie la biomasse
qui peut être utilisé dans l'industrie
utiliser pour les biocarburants et
l'hydrogène et donc il serait
intéressant effectivement que les futurs
stratégies d'accélération ou leur mise à
jour englobe cette vision d'ensemble
merci
Nadia
oui merci beaucoup pardon je suis arrivé
avec un petit peu de retard mais en
jongle un petit peu ces jours-ci je vous
avais dit que en effet c'est un marché
mondial et avec des des fournisseurs qui
sont très agiles et on imagine qu'il y a
même des produits qui doivent pouvoir
arriver à transiter ce repeindre ce
voilà on contrôle pas forcément quand
c'est mondial donc est-ce que sans aller
jusqu'au protectionnisme mais si on veut
aller vers plus de souveraineté vous
imaginez qu'il faut des mesures
législatives ou réglementaires pour
arriver à protéger un petit peu mieux
nos productions nationales et s'assurer
que il soit pas trop en distorsion de de
prix
très clairement on a sur ces sujets là à
la fois des enjeux de souveraineté et
puis même tout simplement d'efficacité
de la démarche pourquoi on fait tout ça
c'est pour réduire concrètement les
émissions de CO2 donc si si on a des
productions qui sont vraiment des
carbonées même totalement
le son le serait totalement on pense par
exemple à l'hydrogène pour être produit
avec des énergies renouvelables etc bon
et qu'on est capable de le tracer
d'avoir effectivement une traçabilité
la question d'une composante de
d'hydrogène vert de ce type dans notre
mix c'est pas quelque chose de
absolument scandaleux si on revanche on
est sur des choses qu'on a du mal à
tracer en termes de qualité et qui en
plus pourrait ne pas être aussi vert
qu'on nous levant alors à ce moment-là
c'est l'objectif global qu'on serait en
train de manquer et sur l'importation
d'un certain nombre de produits
peut-être
faudrait-il que puisqu'il est maintenant
acté mais son périmètre est en cours
d'évolution que le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
s'intéresse
à ces importations si elle comporte une
part de de CO2 que le CO2 soit produit
entre guillemets à l'extérieur de
l'Europe et ensuite importé ou produits
chez nous sachant absolument rien au
problème de de lutte contre le
changement climatique donc là on aurait
besoin effectivement que ce mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone je suis pas je le
connais pas suffisamment bien pour
savoir s'il est s'il est prévu que les
importations de
produits carbonés
certains des vecteurs qui sont imaginés
ici puissent être touchés ça je sais pas
si toi David tu tu as la réponse sur le
mécanisme d'ajustement aux frontières
pas précisément sur le
on a également des d'autres dispositifs
qui existent pour la traçabilité au
niveau européen notamment les directives
raid 2 et Red 3 sur la traçabilité et la
durabilité des notamment de la biomasse
donc tout ce qui est biocarburant et là
le point à avoir en tête c'est que ce
sont des directives qui évoluent vite on
est seulement en train de transposer red
2 que Red 3 arrive avec des questions
très importantes d'ailleurs sur des
sujets autre que
ceux des voilà que ceux des
biocarburants mais
donc là il y a une difficulté à suivre
finalement mais mais on peut quand même
être assez rassuré sur les critères de
durabilité qui sont incluses dans ces
directives la question c'est au niveau
mondial enfin voilà comment ça peut
faire petite tâche d'encre dans un
environnement en dehors de l'Europe
c'est bien de
comme on est en effet Martine Bertin
donc c'est une actrice de la Savoie
merci président oui par rapport parmi
enfin pour la mise en œuvre et vous le
disiez il faut effectivement comment
accentuer quel politique mettre en
oeuvre pour accentuer le développement à
la fois des biocarburants mais aussi de
l'hydrogène comment vous articulez-vous
par rapport aux appels à projets
européens quel accompagnement des
entreprises donc direct ou pas comment
est-ce que cela peut se mettre en oeuvre
dans le futur plan pour une industrie
verte par exemple quels sont les
interventions comment à quel niveau
avez-vous intervenir merci
les appels à projets
ipsi
par exemple
oui il y a un certain nombre des
dispositifs qui sont mis en place par
l'État notamment pour le soutien de
l'hydrogène qui vont être basés sur des
projets européens d'intérêt commun ou
projets
[Musique]
donc on est clairement parti prenant de
ces dispositifs aux côtés la direction
générale des entreprises pour que
effectivement il y ait un financement à
la fois d'usine dans le cadre de
partenariats européens
usine d'équipements qui soient cohérent
au niveau européen parce que voilà au
niveau européen on estime que sujet
d'hydrogène et un sujet d'intérêt
premier qui nécessite qu'on n'autorise
de dépasser les taux d'encadrement des
aides d'État donc c'est tout l'objet de
ces pièces qui ont permis là de voilà de
de d'identifier des projets à financer
donc c'est à mon sens un principal
articulation avec les appels à projets
européens
donc voilà un accompagnement des
entreprises qui va se faire enfin est-ce
qu'il y a déjà quel est le nombre ou
est-ce qu'il y a déjà beaucoup de mises
en oeuvre beaucoup de dossiers que vous
accompagnez et quelle prévision pour
vous par rapport à ce projet de loi sur
l'industrie verte qui sera présentée
avant l'été
en train de chercher le nombre
d'entreprises
très honnêtement sur le projet de
l'industrie verte je vais répondre tout
de suite on est aujourd'hui consulté on
travaille effectivement
notamment vous savez un savon de groupe
de travail ont été mis en place pour
préparer ce texte avec un binôme souvent
dans un chef d'entreprise quelqu'un issu
de la société civile ou un scientifique
et puis un élu parlementaire et donc on
sait que ces groupes travaillent
puisqu'ils consultent et s'entretiennent
avec nos
collaborateurs de l'ADEME on n'a pas
pour l'instant encore tout à fait les
orientations qui vont qui vont être
particulièrement mises en avant dans ce
dans ce projet de l'industrie verte
l'idée elle rejoint beaucoup
effectivement ce qu'on évoque depuis
tout à l'heure
à la fois accompagné les entreprises
dans la transition et faire de cette
transition notamment énergétique une
opportunité de réindustrialisation pour
pour notre territoire donc c'est réglé
en partie de des verrous qui existent
aujourd'hui des difficultés qui peuvent
que peuvent aujourd'hui rencontrer un
certain nombre de chefs d'entreprise
ou de start-up sur
concrétiser les opportunités couvrent la
transition écologique parce que on se
focalise parfois sur les secteurs qui
vont être impactés négativement imagine
bien mais s'ouvrent aussi dans cette
transition des opportunités je crois que
l'objet principal de du projet de loi
industrie verte c'est effectivement de
donner
un peu plus de facilité à ces projets
pour qu'il voit le jour mais on n'a pas
de on n'est pas à ce stade
destinataire d'un projet de loi
et concernant les appels à projet
donc notamment alors il y a énormément
d'appels à projets par l'ADN donc c'est
pas évident de vous donner la le nombre
total sur l'hydrogène le total il était
cité 14 nouveaux appels à 14 nouveaux
projets sur les écosystèmes hydrogène on
peut retenir le chiffre de 35 à 40
écosystème en tout qui ont été financés
par l'ADEME depuis en trois vagues
depuis 2018 donc ça c'est voilà ce sont
des projets locaux sur les territoires
et à l'inverse enfin à l'inverse où de
façon très complémentaire les projets
d'usine de bioraffinerie dont je parlais
tout à l'heure pour les carburants
aériens on a soutenu donc des des études
de préfet habilité là sur à peu près 5
gros projets mais quand je vous dis gros
projet voilà les enveloppes de
financement de quelques-uns de ces
projets sont supérieurs à 500 millions
par projet voilà donc ce sont comme je
vous dis des investissements massifs
véritablement des énormes unités
donc ça c'est en cours de voilà ce sont
des études de préfiguration
pour compléter sur sur ce que vient de
dire David on a une chance et que le
domaine de l'hydrogène aujourd'hui il y
a une vraie effervescence industrielle
et
les 14 projets qui ont été retenus dans
le dernier appel ils ont été choisis
parmi je crois 56 projets donc on a
quand même un vrai mobilisation et à la
fois des élus locaux qui sont souvent à
l'origine de la mise en relation
de ceux qui peuvent produire l'hydrogène
et puis ceux qui qui pourraient avoir
vocation à l'utiliser donc se
rapprochement il est souvent sur une
base territoriale et donc il y a une
vraie effervescence et et des effets
d'apprentissage certains des projets qui
sont qui ont qui sont retoqués puisque
c'est le troisième appel à projet de que
gère l'ADEME sur ses écosystèmes locaux
et il y a un quatrième va sortir là dans
les dans les jours qui viennent il était
prévu il est prévu de le sortir au mois
de mars vont pouvoir en ayant en
améliorant entre guillemets leur dossier
en allant encore un peu plus loin bien
reconducter donc à cet appel à projet
donc on
essaie de que ce soit pas qui est pas
simplement 40 perdants à chaque appel à
projet mais que que que qui est une
vraie courbe d'apprentissage pour pour
les territoires qui s'engagent sur ces
sur ces questions
en termes de de
mesures aussi d'accompagnement qui
peuvent vous intéresser en tant que élu
locaux il y a question de la
planification territoriale et nationale
ont cité tout à l'heure des
projets la question du de la
récupération du CO2 par exemple
nécessaire à ses usines ça s'inscrit
clairement dans une dynamique que vous
avez peut-être dont vous avez peut-être
entendu parler qui s'appelle zyback
aujourd'hui donc les zones industrielles
bas carbone qui fait partie de la
stratégie d'accélération
des carbonation de l'industrie où on
accompagne des zones industrielles donc
des gros zone industrielles à définir
des stratégies de décarbonation et à
identifier donc des
[Musique]
puisque vous êtes sur le sujet
et comment vous voyez l'articulation
entre l'État et les stratégies les
collectivités territoriales et notamment
de nos régions
sur le sur le sujet de l'hydrogène ou
sur le le plus globalement bon on a je
crois aujourd'hui par le biais des
appels à projets des
collectivités qui se mobilisent qui
trouve qui trouve généralement
un certain nombre d'appui et donc dans
les dans les partenaires des industriels
ou des territoires il y a très
régulièrement des coalitions de
collectivités et donc l'état finalement
met à disposition sur sur ces appels à
projets par exemple de ceux qui sont les
écosystèmes locaux hydrogène des moyens
de groupements de collectivités qui
souvent inclus le bloc communal et et la
région dans laquelle se trouve se trouve
le projet on a des partenariats un peu
plus un peu plus structurants avec avec
les régions mais effectivement
aujourd'hui
il y a une action un peu à de niveau
l'État soutient un certain nombre
d'acteurs l'émergence à certains nombre
de d'innovations et puis ensuite
accompagne les territoires qui qui
décident d'agir d'avancer dans les
domaines où il y a besoin d'une
dimension d'une dimension territoriale
typiquement les ibaks qui sont
aujourd'hui trois Le Havre Dunkerque est
fausse on a on a des acteurs locaux qui
sont absolument convaincus
qu'effectivement le CO2 des haut
fourneaux de d'Arcelor peut-être utilisé
pour produire des électro carburants
en combinant cela avec avec de
l'hydrogène produite par ailleurs de
manière durable donc là finalement
l'état vient
concrétiser ces visions locales globale
ce qui moi on voit mes thèmes un peu de
prédilection qui est absolument
convaincu que c'est comme ça qu'on
réussir à la transition écologique pas
simplement l'émergence de
d'électrocarburant ou la production de
carburant de soutenable ponctuellement
mais sur l'ensemble des sujets ce sont
effectivement des collectivités locales
qui se mobilisent et qui avec l'aide et
le moyen et les moyens financiers de
l'État et bien font aboutir des projets
on est je crois c'est une bonne
illustration de ce à mon avis est une
méthode assez efficace sur les
différents compartiments de transition
écologique
je posais cette question parce que
dans la territoire où j'habite les
agriculteurs sont déjà versés dans les
rêves médiatisation méthanisation
mabélise déjà de la biomasse
si j'ai bien lu
l'Académie
des technologies dit qu'il faudrait en
600 millions de tonnes pour l'aérien en
bio-carburant donc quand on voit ça
c'est carrément donné le problème de la
biomasse ou Vatel quelle priorité et
donc si les territoires partent parce
que là sur mon territoire elle sert à
faire à la fois du gaz faire tourner des
cars faire chauffer des voilà je vais
dire qu'à un moment donné il va bien
falloir articuler tout ça bien sur un
autre aspect la biomasse elle nécessite
d'utiliser la terre qui pour le moment
peut être agricole donc il y aura bien
aussi une réflexion amenée entre quelle
est la part sur un territoire qui va
pour l'agriculture et qui est la part
qui va pour la biomasse
tout à fait alors
dans le temps la consistance de
effectivement de cette coopération entre
l'initiatives locales et le cadre
international c'est je crois vraiment ce
qu'on appelle la planification
écologique c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on
peut essayer d'imaginer
d'être en travaillant par exemple sur la
disponibilité de la biomasse pas
simplement en théorique au niveau global
ou à l'horizon 2050 mais mais
régionaliser et descendu à des mailles à
des échelons territoriaux plus plus
infras parce que la biomasse qui est
disponible dans le dans les Pyrénées
elle va pas servir effectivement à
alimenter les les productions du Grand
Est ou du Nord de la France il y a un
vrai sujet besoin de de régionaliser
mais on est en train effectivement de de
regarder de faire ce travail là et de
voir aussi d'évaluer aussi tous les
gisements possibles dans les pour parler
des méthaniseurs et lien avec
effectivement les agriculteurs qui sont
souvent qui portent souvent ces projets
ces projets là aujourd'hui à partir du
et à partir du 1er janvier prochain sont
interdits les biodéchets dans les
ordures ménagères bon voilà un gisement
pour le coup tout à fait considérable
peut aussi alimenter les méthaniseurs et
réduire justement la part de des
productions agricoles qu'on utilisera
dans ces méthaniseurs ou en tout cas
plus facilement tenir la part des 15 %
de des béthaniseurs qui doivent fous
accueillir des productions qui
pourraient être à destinées à
destination alimentaire donc je crois
que le sujet il est il est vraiment
aujourd'hui qu'on arrive à bâtir des
trajectoires pas simplement au niveau
national mais elle est déclinée des
échelons au moins régionaux et si ce
n'est pour vérifier que les projets ont
une place et et apportent et contribue
effectivement efficacement résolution
des difficultés et il va falloir à
certains moments arriver aussi à flécher
les usages de cette biomasse on va pas
pouvoir la mobiliser
sur tous les sujets et donc
dans les domaines dans lesquels par
exemple pour la production de chaleur
on peut
voilà effectivement sur un certain
nombre de sites se poser la question de
recourir peut-être davantage à la
géothermie pour pour aller et soulager
effectivement l'utilisation d'une
biomasse qui serait disponible et qui
pourrait être indispensable à la
décarbonation de d'autres usages
peut-être pour
compléter enfin cette priorisation des
usages et les elle est complexe elle est
complexe parce qu'elle elle inclut des
questions de rendement énergétiques et
inclus des questions de difficultés à
décarboner certains secteurs il y a une
initiative locale de faire une usine de
fabrication de l'électrocarburant
en utilisant de la biomasse et de
l'électricité sur un site donné et ce
que c'est la façon la plus optimale
d'utiliser cette biomasse en concurrence
avec d'autres usages et ça c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident d'y répondre
il faut avoir en tête qu'à chaque fois
qu'on ajoute une étape de transformation
de la dans la chaîne si vous passez de
l'électricité à l'hydrogène puis de
l'hydrogène à des carburants recombinés
avec du CO2 chaque fois que vous ajoutez
une étape vous perdez quasiment 30% de
rendement et donc de la biomasse
ligneuse si on la brûle pour répondre à
des usages de chaleur d'un réseau de
chaleur on va avoir 90% de rendement si
on décide d'en faire du gaz on va
pyrogazéifier cette biomasse peut-être
descendre à 60% de rendement donc
l'énergéticien de vous dira bah non il
vaut mieux la brûler que de perdre 30%
de rendement pour faire du gaz mais si
on prend en compte la difficulté à
décarboner certains usages notamment la
rien on se dit voilà ça peut valoir le
coup quand même de perdre du rendement
parce que ce cet usage là je sais pas le
décarboner autrement mais il y a besoin
de cette équilibre entre le l'initiative
locale l'initiative conjointe d'une
d'une collectivité d'un ou plusieurs
industriels et cette vision aussi
planificatrice de l'État dans la
priorisation des usages de cette
biomasse et je pense ça c'est pas c'est
pas du tout évident peut-être pour aussi
reprendre la question
des des stratégies régionales enfin des
et notamment vous évoquez peut-être en
en sous-jacent les seradettes enfin
comment les stratégies régionales
s'articulent aussi avec les stratégies
de l'État aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore
une complète cohérence entre les
objectifs fixés par l'État par exemple
dans la PPE et dans la SNBC et les
objectifs fixés
dans chaque région la mise en place mes
bon sens la mise en place notamment des
comités régionaux de l'énergie va
permettre d'avoir normalement une sorte
de déclinaison de la programmation plus
réelle de l'énergie territoire par
territoire
sous-entendu ça va pas être une
homothétie enfin vous en avez
parfaitement confiance et conscience les
territoires ont chacun leur
particularité certains vont développer
plus une technologie qu'une autre et le
partage de l'effort ne sera pas non plus
complètement homothétique et ça c'est
c'est pas évident donc je pense qu'il y
a un juste croisement à faire entre les
objectifs qui sont à remonter par les
territoires et le
la correspondance avec les objectifs de
l'État et peut-être un dernier point sur
la concurrence avec l'alimentation que
vous avez évoqué monsieur le Président
l'un des sujets autour du développement
des biocarburants et bien entendu celui
du changement d'affectation des sols
enfin on l'avait pas encore dit mais
c'est quand même important de le
rappeler sur les biocarburants de
première génération on se changement
d'affectation des sols effectivement il
existe enfin et même le changement
d'affectation des sols indirects
c'est-à-dire celui qui est
qui est la conséquence du développement
des biocarburant mais qui n'est pas
volontairement induit par celui qui les
développe mais les conséquences dans
d'autres pays liées au fait que la
surface utilisée pour faire ces biocars
n'est plus utilisables pour faire autre
chose et que ça nécessite d'importer par
ailleurs donc ça normalement les les
directives red2 R3 que je citais tout à
l'heure vise à vraiment limiter les
impacts de ce de ces changements
d'affectation des sols c'est aussi pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui l'état n'envisage pas
de développer outre mesure les
biocarbures première génération on a 7
de le carburant de première génération
dans les carburants aujourd'hui on
pourrait imaginer pourquoi on en met pas
plus justement pour ces raisons
environnementales qui font que on
préfère s'orienter vers des
biocarburants qui n'auront moins
d'impact sur la concurrence d'usage des
sols
merci
monsieur rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président je viens juste une seconde sur
les conflits d'usage que vous avez
évoqué plusieurs fois et puis on
revient qu'il y a des conflits d'usage
et que vous l'abordez même à l'instant
quand on réfléchit du point de vue des
on oublie souvent l'industrie les modes
de transport etc bon effectivement
chacun va parfois
souhaiter utiliser tel ou tel mode
téléergy bon et puis après vous disiez
vous-même que après tout la biomasse
c'est pas non plus extensible à l'infini
c'est le président abordé tout à l'heure
la question de la production d'énergie
elle-même des carbonée bon
alors à quel moment et comment vous
pensez qu'on peut essayer de progresser
pour avoir une synthèse alors moi j'aime
pas beaucoup de mots planification
à penser que si on avait une stratégie
une déclinaison y compris territoriale
des mécanismes incitatifs
et une évaluation claire ça serait déjà
pas si mal je sais pas s'il faut être
vraiment planificateur et est-ce qu'on
en a d'ailleurs les moyens parce que
plutôt est-ce qu'on va dire on interdit
tel usage
quand même j'ai aussi le sentiment que
les appels à projets excusez-moi vous
n'êtes pas du tout visé je trouve très
bien tout ce que fait l'ADEME mais on
fait des appels à projets quand on sait
pas quoi faire quand on veut montrer
qu'il y a des innovation on veut la
susciter on veut l'encourager mais ça
fait pas une stratégie il y a un moment
quand même où il faut aussi s'interroger
et se dire alors c'est pour ça que faut
qu'on regarde mieux l'exemple allemand
ou l'exemple américain elle a le
sentiment que par exemple vous évoquiez
monsieur le Président les questions des
carburants synthétiques pour l'aérien il
y a un choix qui est fait aux États-Unis
ils y vont
on pourrait aussi s'interroger sur les
conflits d'usage s'agissant de
l'automobile on a vu la position
allemande
visiblement ils ont tendance à
considérer qu'ils vont garder le
thermique mais sans doute
peut-être vont-ils le garder avec ce
même type de carburant est-ce qu'on va
est-ce qu'on va pas vers un conflit
là-dessus d'ailleurs si vous pouvez nous
éclairer sur l'analyse que vous avez de
la position allemande ça serait pas mal
et puis pour dire les choses rapidement
tout à l'heure je crois que vous parlez
de note de la taille des investissements
est-ce qu'on sait se dire moi j'entends
parfois dire il faut mettre 5 milliards
10 milliards
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs même
simplement sur les carburants durable
et du coup comment on fait sur les
carburants durable j'ai à peu près au
jour aujourd'hui entendu que après tout
maintenant le problème c'est de financer
alors avec la question que vous posiez
monsieur le Président de sortie
effectivement est-ce qu'on connaît la
fois 5 est-ce qu'on est à plus que X5
jusqu'à quel moment le marché peut-il
absorber ça
on dirait d'inconnu 1 x 2 sur le
kérosène en très peu de temps donc ça
montre que quand même il y a une
certaine élasticité sur la visibilité je
crois que je suis directeur qui élaboré
tout à l'heure bon vous disiez red2 red
il y a toutes ces discussions sur le
paquet européen et nous-mêmes on a aussi
un certain nombre de textes législatif
et autres qui vont intervenir c'est sans
doute pas la meilleure façon de rassurer
les industriels ou en tout cas les
investisseurs là aussi comment on peut
s'y mettre pour aboutir à quand même
quelque chose de clair au bout d'un
moment il faut aider l'investissement
mais il faut aussi se dire qu'une autre
façon d'aider l'investissement c'est
qu'à donner une visibilité sur le moyen
un moyen long terme parce que sinon les
investisseurs vont pas y aller
si à un moment donné il y a un
changement ça paraît un problème voilà
donc c'est pour ça que quand on évoque
la panoplie d'investissement et comme
vous l'avez dit fort justement le besoin
de faire
s'emboîter entre guillemets pardon pour
la formule la planification territoriale
et en tout cas la planification
nationale
on sent bien que
on est un stade où il faut franchir ce
pas voilà comment le comment comment y
arriver
je pense pas qu'il faille entrer dans un
débat ou même sur une polémique lexicale
sur planification ou pas l'idée c'est
quand même effectivement de
d'essayer de ce monde fini de ressources
que dans lequel dans lequel nous sommes
d'essayer d'anticiper ce que vont être
les besoins qui vont se manifester et
dans le temps d'avoir des outils donc de
suivi de la demande d'une ressource ou
d'une autre l'évolution qu'elle va
connaître et de sa disponibilité parce
que
il va de soi que dans cette dans ces
dans ces transitions si si nous
arrivions à une impasse sur la
disponibilité de biomasse je crois qu'on
se trouverait tous dans une situation
assez dramatique on aurait reproduit
avec
l'alternative justement au fossiles
qu'on cherche à sortir exactement les
mêmes impasses que celles dans lesquels
on se trouve aujourd'hui avec le pétrole
gaz donc
et on est effectivement quand même
plutôt dans la tradition française de
planification plutôt que de la
planification soviétique je vous rassure
tout de suite je le rapporteur voilà
vous n'avez pas trop de doute très bien
pas je crois de velléité de
d'étatisation ou de l'ensemble de
l'économie on sait bien qu'on a en face
une myriade d'acteurs privés encore que
je pense dans ces exercices de
planification la discussion avec les
acteurs privés et est assez est assez
importante pour savoir justement quels
sont les stratégies des uns et des
autres et essayer de de s'y tenir
ce qui n'est pas complètement réglé
c'est c'est de quels outils on dispose
pour corriger éventuellement les
trajectoires mais commencez déjà par
suivre sur la biomasse
la chose au niveau global au niveau
national donc un travail que l'ADEM est
en train de faire aujourd'hui avec le
secrétariat général pour la
planification écologique sur le bouclage
de la biomasse et la descente des de ce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui être les besoins
au niveau régional ça ce sont des choses
qui sont sur lesquelles les
collaborateurs de David travaille en ce
moment donc on va déjà se rendre compte
de des marges dont on dispose et il
faudra effectivement se doter de moyens
d'action c'est à dire que très
concrètement
l'ADEME aujourd'hui a des fonds
notamment à fond chaleur renouvelable
dans lequel elle soutient elle aide des
projets
voilà un fond au travers duquel il est
possible d'orienter plus ou moins la
demande vers une source renouvelable
qu'une autre donc on a des outils mais
je pense que ce qui est vraiment
fondamental c'est de poser d'abord un
suivi extrêmement rigoureux de ce qu'on
croit être les tendances du marché et
les possibilités parce que sur la
biomasse il y a une utilisation que je
crois qu'on a pas cité jusqu'à présent
mais qui est celle depuis de carbone et
qu'on a quand même aussi besoin de pas
dégrader ce stock de carbone stocké
sinon notre situation enfin ou plutôt le
défi à relever sera encore plus
important alors sur les appels à projet
je sais et pour être un élu local qui a
pesté comme beaucoup d'autres contre les
appels à projets je vais pas
comment dire par renier ce que ce que
j'ai dit pendant des années ça suppose
effectivement une ingénierie importante
de la part de celui ou de ceux qui sont
appelés à déposer les projets et donc il
y a un effet
un effet effectivement
de sélection
et on a un sujet alors si on parle de
collectivité l'ADEME a plus de 700
chargés de mission et en équivalent
temps plein quel finance dans les
collectivités françaises c'est
probablement pas assez mais c'est une
contribution assez significative
significative pour essayer qu'il y ait
justement de l'ingénierie au plus près
de ceux qui développent les projets
c'est pas forcément sur nos sujets
d'aujourd'hui mais on a des chargés de
mission qui travaillent sur l'économie
circulaire le développement des
renouvelables et malgré tout on est un
petit peu plus près de notre question
d'aujourd'hui ou les mobilités durables
et donc il y a effectivement je pense le
besoin d'accompagner
on veut déposer on veut voir déposer des
projets et surtout dans une logique de
massification de généralisation visage
que les gens aillent cette question de
l'ingénierie est centrale néanmoins ça
reste quand même un outil finalement
assez impartial et assez objectif de qui
permet de financer à coup sûr les
meilleurs projets et donc ça correspond
aussi bien à des phases de d'amont des
phases où on soutient à l'innovation où
on soutient l'émergence de
fonctionnement et de systèmes ensuite il
faut certainement passer à d'autres
outils qui permettent un plus gros débit
et qui sont moins exigeants sur sur
l'ingénierie mais je crois pas qu'on
soit enfin
le contenu de la charge de travail que
ça représente on dépose on ne fait pas
d'appel à projet je vous assure
à défaut de stratégie on fait
généralement des stratégies et avec
ensuite des appels à projets pour les
mettre en oeuvre donc c'est plutôt comme
ça en tout cas à la dame qu'on essaie
que les choses que les choses
fonctionnent
sur le la question du positionnement en
changeant de position en tout cas de
l'extériorisation d'une forme d'opinion
dissidente de l'Allemagne sur sur le
véhicule thermique
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est ont-ils les moyens de leurs
ambitions ou de cette affirmation parce
que on est quand même dans un système où
on a quand même des décisions qui ont
été prises annoncées d'ores et déjà par
la Commission européenne je ne sais pas
quelle est la capacité de l'Allemagne je
vois du coup
coup je cherche à comprendre par quel
vecteur ils vont faire passer
ce souhait d'un changement ça me semble
pas très évident je vois pas le
Parlement européen entre aujourd'hui
être très très réceptif à l'idée de de
revoir ces dates là même si les dates
qui ont été fixées même si les Allemands
constituent une part non négligeable des
parlementaires européens ils ont pas à
eux seuls la capacité de de changer ce
type de
décision donc j'ai même pour tout dire
tout à fait du mal à comprendre quel est
l'effet utile de ces déclarations je
sais pas si David tu as tu as d'autres
éléments d'analyse sur sur cette
question je vais terminer peut-être sur
les
parce que le chiffrage des
investissements ça on les a la question
c'est
en fait la part des investissements qui
doit être soutenu sur fonds publics
parce que très honnêtement
des révolutions industrielles
technologiques on en a déjà vécu
plusieurs dans la mesure où cette
mobilisation d'argent privée avec un
rendement privé positif derrière je
crois que c'est simplement le
fonctionnement normal de l'économie et
il y a heureusement dans le dans la
définition des cadres qu'on compose là
je vais revenir sur les sur les
incitations réglementaires on essaie
quand même d'orienter le plus possible
alors ça se fait beaucoup au niveau
européen mais au niveau national avec
les textes dont on dispose on essaie
aussi de faire ça les anticipations et
les investissements des acteurs privés
sur le sur le le thermique ce qui est
intéressant c'est effectivement d'avoir
fixé quand elle était fixée il y a
quelques années un terme assez lointain
qui permettent aux acteurs de
l'automobile alors ils ont pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux trouvés que
c'est il manquait de temps etc trop
rapide mais
de leur donner justement un pas de temps
qui leur permettent de revoir leurs
investissements et donc nouveau cadre
réglementaire et bien de procéder à la
mutation de leur appareil industriel
c'est vrai que les législations se
succèdent mais enfin
sur
review en matière d'aviation on a des
objectifs fixés à 2050 qui quand même
permettent d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui
d'avoir une visibilité et permettre
l'émergence de projet qu'on est en train
de financer aujourd'hui
toujours essayer effectivement de donner
de la visibilité aux acteurs privés
parce que c'est ce qui leur permet
effectivement de faire toutes leurs
parts du travail avec des
investissements dont ils attendent
naturellement un rendement les choses
sont plus compliquées quand on est sur
des sur des investissements qu'on
demande totalement sur de courtes
périodes à des acteurs privés et qui
n'ont pas une rentabilité fin frontières
ou économique intrinsèque c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué c'est pour ça qu'on
mobilise autant d'argent sur la
décarbonation industrielle c'est parce
que tout ce qui tout ce qui touche à
l'efficacité énergétique
dans les entreprises pas de difficulté à
les financer il y a un surtout avec des
niveaux de prix de l'énergie comme on en
a aujourd'hui une vraie rentabilité
derrière le fait de décarboner là c'est
en fait l'économie c'est une externalité
le carbone et donc on leur demande
d'intégrer cela et de le gérer de
décarboner et donc c'est là qu'on a
besoin effectivement de mobiliser des
fonds publics donc le vrai sujet c'est
quelle est la part des évolutions et des
investissements qui qui doit être aidé
sur fonds publics parce qu'elle ne
pourrait pas être supportée ou qu'elle
générerait des surcoûts insupportables
pour pour les acteurs privés
c'est vrai qu'il y a des objectifs
clairs pour 2050 mais
la question de la définition
concrète technique réglementaire des
objectifs
c'est pas assez bas c'est pas un sujet
qui est quand même bien stabilisé on le
voit bien et donc là il y a quand même
un moment où il va falloir aussi
sécuriser tout le monde parce que sinon
on va voir des par exemple sur la
compensation pour prendre un autre sujet
il y a des compagnies
étrangères je crois oui c'est ça qui
sont aériennes qui sont partis sur
des contrats de compensation et qui sont
rendus compte après coup que non
réglementairement c'était pas bien
c'était pas ça je pense l'exemple là ça
a marqué à l'époque donc là il va s'agir
d'avoir une définition claire sur ce que
ce qu'on attend d'eux voilà sur
l'hydrogène sur les carburants
synthétiques notamment
pour que l'investissement privé soit
sécurisé par un cadre juridique et
technique
de quoi tout le monde a un peu se
regarder pour ça que je veux dire
peut-être juste pour compléter sur ce
point là la programme la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie qui sera votée
par les deux Chambres va être un outil
pour donner en partie cette visibilité
là puisque si elle traite bien la
question des électrocarburants elle peut
donner un point d'étape intermédiaire à
2030 2035 sur leur place et cette
programmation pour annuelle de l'énergie
elle sert justement à ça à donner de la
visibilité sur des investissements
à 10 ans voilà
d'autre part après ce sont le
législateur à d'ores et déjà dans la
définition de la taxe notamment la tireu
verte qui est la taxe sur les carburant
rendu éligible un certain nombre de de
son hydrogène sur etc sur sur les
différents
carburants durables ce qui donne aussi
de la visibilité
aux producteurs peut-être vous posiez
des questions sur l'Allemagne et la
stratégie allemande
la stratégie de conserver du thermique
et de mettre des électrocarburants dans
les moteurs
est une stratégie qui d'un point de vue
de la durabilité peut poser des
questions les moteurs thermiques ont un
rendement de 30% des électrocarburants
comme je le disais tout à l'heure ont un
rendement aussi sur la chaîne qui est
moins bon que
l'électricité ou l'hydrogène donc voilà
un point de vue environnemental ça peut
poser question
et d'autre part
l'Allemagne se trouve dans une situation
quand même assez différente de la France
pour avoir vu certains de leurs
scénarios prospectifs sur l'hydrogène
ils envisagent d'importer encore
massivement d'hydrogène à hauteur de 700
je crois en 2050 mais importation
d'hydrogène décarbonée ça c'est la
stratégie allemande aujourd'hui quand on
leur dit bah alors quand on leur pose la
question de la souveraineté c'est les
scénario de la Dena de l'agence d'agence
allemande de l'énergie
quand on leur parle de souveraineté mais
ils vont répondre bah écoutez
aujourd'hui en importe 2700 terawattoirs
d'énergie en Allemagne donc si demain on
en importe plus que 700 c'est déjà pas
si mal
certain mais donc voilà leur stratégie
si vous parlez de leur avant sur les
électrocarburants c'est qu'une partie de
ces carburants vont être fait à partir
d'hydrogène et que leur stratégie sur
l'hydrogène est en partie d'importer
massivement cet hydrogène décarbonée
et puis peut-être sur les sur la
biomasse
Boris parlé de la l'impact aussi sur les
prélèvements enfin tous nos scénarios
envisagent de multiplier par deux la
valorisation énergétique de la biomasse
à l'horizon 2050 principalement de la
biomasse agricole de d'origine agricole
il faut avoir en tête qu'effectivement
la nécessité d'avoir une vision
systémique et quand même importante pour
vérifier qu'on dégrade pas le puits de
carbone c'est ce que disait Boris tout à
l'heure et que d'autre part ça repose
aussi sur des changements de société qui
sont importants et notamment je cite
parce qu'il est pas il négligeable et
souvent pas forcément toujours accepté
mais la réduction de la part du chept el
bovin notamment puisque vous savez qu'il
y a 80% de la surface 75% de la surface
agricole française aujourd'hui qui est
une surface pour l'alimentation animale
et donc si ces scénarios mais que ce
soit les scénario d'adem ou scénario la
SNBC envisage une baisse de cette part
agricole pour l'alimentation animale ce
qui permet justement d'identifier du
gisement pour faire de l'énergie et
notamment du vocabulaire voilà il faut
avoir en tête cette voilà de de
la vision énergétique induit aussi des
questions sur les régimes alimentaires
bien monsieur le rapporteur les vies sur
le groupe Nadia
bon simplement avant de se quitter vous
avez parlé vous avez fait quatre
scénarios et puis pour aller vers la
décarbonation 2050 et vous avez parlé de
trois scénarios pour l'aérien sur ces
trois scénarios est-ce que ces scénarios
arrivent en 2050
à la bicarbonation et
est-ce qu'ils arrivent tous les trois ou
est-ce qu'il y en a qu'un qui arrive ou
aucun et celui qui arrive le plus proche
de la décoration qu'est-ce que ça
implique
alors donnez-moi alors lui effectivement
l'idée c'était bien de bâtir des
scénarios le plus proche de la
neutralité carbone alors ils arrivent
tous à un niveau élevé de décarbonation
de l'ordre de
70% je dirais
mais avec des leviers différents voilà
c'était c'était le cadrage de cette
étude là soit on est carbone via les
leviers technologiques sont en
décarbones via des leviers plus
comportementaux et un scénario qui est
qui est entre les deux
je n'ai je vous dirais des bêtises si
j'allais plus loin mais voilà tous les
trois scénarios arrivent à un fort
niveau de décarbonation et ce qui est
voilà ce qui était intéressant c'est que
ces scénarios ils ont été bâtis avec la
filière
donc à la fois voilà enfin les les
compagnies aériennes etc
donc c'est une co-construction c'est
intéressant d'avoir cette démarche de
co-construction puisque forcément la
filière dans initialement chercher
plutôt à promouvoir le scénario où on
conserve une augmentation forte du
trafic finalement la réflexion qui a pu
avoir avec eux montrer que des scénarios
alternatifs pouvaient avoir une certaine
pertinence également par rapport à des
questions de coûts ou des questions
d'impact sur prix du billet d'avion par
exemple
mais on veut
et propose une forte réduction de
l'utilisation d'avion en termes de
sobriété
n'osez pas le dire mais si vous avez pu
vérifier
non mais
pourra rajouter
une réponse au questionnaire si vous
voulez avec justement les synthèse des
conclusions de cette étude spécifique
sur l'aérien oui ça nous renvoie un peu
à la multiplicité on pourrait presque
faire une cartographie d'ailleurs des
des procédures des temporalité des
stratégies etc parce qu'il est quand
même un scénario du corak qui est le
conseil de recherche de la science
civile qui est en gros réunit les
pouvoirs publics et les chercheurs les
industriels bon
j'ai cru comprendre que
la DGAC
la DGEC notamment les industriels et
autres essayer de se mettre d'accord sur
un scénario et moi ce que je j'entends
aujourd'hui c'est quand même l'idée que
les carburants faudrait pas parler
beaucoup d'hydrogène
que les carburants disent synthétique
durable
permettrait alors selon la filière
semble-t-il on les entendre d'aller
quand même beaucoup plus loin que les
70% évoqué tout à l'heure
il y a un moment où il va falloir aussi
là là aboutir à décision et investir
parce que vous l'avez rappelé les
objectifs d'un coopération il y a un
seuil
de d'homologation à 50% aujourd'hui dans
kérosène
est-ce que le seuil pourra être relevé
sans doute faut-il
le faire mais il faut le faire avec des
précautions d'usage quand même pour
regarder dans le temps ce que ça ce que
ça donne
on devrait quand même enfin aboutir
quelque chose qui est que dans les 25
prochaines années c'est d'abord les
carburants synthétiques durable qui vont
permettre de faire un grand pas pour la
décarbonation d'aérien après jusqu'où ça
nous amène et à quel moment on peut
bâtir un scénario différent sur
l'hydrogène
peut-être que les deux d'ailleurs
peuvent d'une certaine manière converger
parce que pour faire du carburant
synthétique durable il faut de
l'hydrogène enfin en tout cas c'est une
bonne façon d'en faire sans doute y
a-t-il des intérêts communs sur ce point
là en particulier mais bon
merci beaucoup de tous les éléments que
vous avez apportés alors on nous a
challenger mais c'est normal
pardon l'anglicisme mais c'est en tout
cas c'est très éclairant et on
poursuivra avec sur l'autorité du
président avec les différents acteurs de
la filière ou des filières en question
bien messieurs merci de nous avoir
accordé du temps et merci de votre
éclairage